grazie io di mestiere faccio il chimico
uso uno di quei microscopi atomici
potentissimi che si vedevano prima
faccio il chimico perché mi affascina da
sempre come piccoli atomi e molecole si
trovino si aggreghino tra loro per
creare strutture di straordinaria
bellezza e complessità come ad esempio
noi
faccio il chimico anche perché sin da
piccolo mi facevo tante domande che ad
altri magari sembravano scontate ad
esempio perché il metallo lucente perché
il vetro e tagliente o trasparente mi
chiedevo da piccolo perché di aveva
messo le vitamine e tutte le cose che
fanno bene nella verdura non nelle
patatine fritte o nel gelato al
cioccolato ad esempio
la chimica mi ha spiegato tante cose mi
ha spiegato che cosa succede nella tazza
del caffè che cosa succede nel nostro
corpo nel cielo sopra di noi anche se
questa storia le patatine fritte ancora
non mi convince del tutto comunque è che
la chimica centri comunque se cosa e
probabilmente lo sapete già
però mi ha spiegato anche questa è
l'idea che oggi vorrei condividere con
voi che questi piccoli atomi e molecole
all'inizio alzato anche il nostro
progresso di tutta l'umanità molto ma
molto di più di qualsiasi imperatore
battaglia o politico che sa che ci sia
stato nella storia
permettetemi quindi stasera di
raccontarvi la nostra storia in maniera
diversa da quello che leggete nei libri
tralasciando tutti i dettagli storici
che avete studiato e concentrandoci
sulle poche rivoluzioni che hanno
davvero insensato in maniera epocale la
nostra vita per capire quanto la nostra
evoluzione c'è stata una vera e propria
rivoluzione
dobbiamo pensare che noi siamo appena
arrivati sul pianeta terra siamo gli
ultimi arrivati
se saremmo come un tweet un sms una
notizia dell'ultima ora
un'ansa per darvi un'idea immaginiamo
che tutta la storia del pianeta sia
qualcosa di grande però qualcosa che
possiamo immaginare immaginiamo che sia
come tutto questo teatro tutta l'altezza
del teatro e la storia della terra la
nascita in cima al tetto e la realtà il
presente ea livello di questo
palcoscenico
se fosse così la vita sarebbe nata sulla
terra più o meno all'altezza del piano
superiore
da lì a qui per la maggior parte della
vita e la terra latera è stata popolata
da esseri molto semplici unicellulari
molto semplice anche abbastanza noiosi
non succede molto per la maggior parte
della vita della terra a poco a poco
questi esseri si aggregano si
organizzano diventano sempre più
complessi sempre più complessi vedete la
vita che scende per fa di noi
i vertebrati la conquista della terra
del mondo emerso animali sempre più
complessi
a un certo punto qui più o meno
all'altezza del mio ombelico
comincerebbe le rade di no
mauri sono grandi forti cattivi morto ma
teniamo lì un po più lontani dominano la
terra per circa 130 milioni di anni
molto ma molto di più di quanto
l'abbiamo dominata a noi più o meno
dall'altezza del mio ombelico a quella
dei miei calzini queen da qui a qui
sembrano destinati a durare in eterno
poi in un battito di ciglia scompaiono
distrutti forse da un asteroide
cominciano i mammiferi che occupano uno
spazio più o meno così si evolvono si
evolvono nessuna notizia dell'uomo
ancora se volgono si evolvono niente
uomini niente uomini l'umanità arriva
più o meno a questa altezza qui tutta
l'evoluzione dell'umanità ha uno
spessore che corrisponde più o meno a
quello della sola delle mie scarpe e la
civiltà
direte voi beh la civiltà avrebbe uno
spessore più o meno così quanto un
cappello
qui c'è tutta la storia che conosciamo
siamo arrivati da molto poco tempo qui
siamo veramente gli ultimi arrivati
eppure siamo riusciti a dominare il
pianeta a colonizzare tutti i continenti
e modificarlo così tanto da rischiare
addirittura di distruggerlo come è
potuto succedere tutto questo la prima
rivoluzione di cui voglio parlare
successe proprio all'inizio durante
l'età della pietra forse voi non ci
crederete ma la cosa più importante
dell'età della pietra era la pietra
bravissimi da un pubblico
intelligentissimo davvero non so che
avete fatta indovinare ma ne sapete
tanti altri esseri viventi usano oggetti
o pietre tante scimmie le lontre i corvi
per alcune azioni ma a un certo punto ne
scoprimmo che non tutte le pietre sono
uguali e inventiamo qualcosa di
straordinario inventammo questo non
sembra un granché vero però noi
a un certo punto scoprimmo che alcune
pietre come la selce o l'ossidiana hanno
delle proprietà simili al vetro vi siete
mai chiesti perché il vetro e tagliente
beh perché gli atomi nel vetro sono
tutti messi in maniera di sordi
mentre nel diamante o in altri cristalli
gli atomi sono ordinati quindi diamante
tenderà a rompersi in direzioni
preferenziali il vetro non ha una
direzione preferenziale in chrome percy
questo sembra uno svantaggio ma per
alcune cose è un vantaggio perché se
colpiamo il vetro si romperà esattamente
lungo la linea d'urto con cui lo
colpiamo quindi questo creerà degli
angoli acuti dei bordi molto taglienti e
affilati in maniera molto semplice gli
esseri primitivi non sapevano di atomi o
di onde d'urto ma impararono presto
questa tecnica creando oggetti come
questi questo sembra un oggetto molto
rozzo ma gli permise di ottenere di
creare oggetti come questo
punte di freccia punte di lancia accette
coltelli rasoi che trasformarono gli
esseri umani da deboli bipedi primitivi
senza zanne senza artigli e con pochi
muscoli nei predatori più letali sulla
faccia della terra
quindi gli uomini primitivi riuscirono
espandersi oltre l'africa procurandosi
carmen e pelliccia colonizzando tutti i
continenti e ovunque arrivarono creare
un enorme estinzioni di massa perché
sterminavano tutti gli animali da carne
da pelliccia
già allora eravamo così potenti da
modificare e danneggiare il nostro
pianeta andò avanti così per centinaia
di miliardi va anni cc espandendo e
colonizza amo tutto e tutti quanti
continenti mangiando bistecche di mammut
quindi la tecnologia usata che a lungo
dall'essere umano è questa qui è la
selce full importantissima per noi
infatti tra l'altro ne parlavo con mia
moglie oggi anche l'anniversario sono
cinque anni che ci amiamo che ci
conosciamo
parlando di anniversari grazie qui in
prima fila
adesso in rossa di capelli adesso eros
anche di faccia comunque e parlando di
anniversari accennava mandava messaggi
di regali ho cercato di spiegarle che la
selce per l'umanità è stata molto più
importante del diamante ma non sono
riuscita a convincerla quindi niente
niente diamanti mi dispiace
grazie non applaudite troppo perché mi
ha rubato il tempo solo pochi minuti
comunque andò avanti così per centinaia
di migliaia di anni
dopodiché un certo punto scoprimmo
qualcosa di meglio della selce
dell'ossidiana scoprimmo questi vi siete
mai chiesti perché i metalli sono così
affascinanti così unici
beh questo perché dipende dagli atomi
mentre nella maggior parte dei solidi
gli atomi sono legati assieme da dei
legami ben precisi quindi se rompiamo
questi legami in meta il materiale si
spacca nel metallo sono tenute assieme
da una specie di marmellata di elettroni
molto resistente ma anche molto
adattabile quindi se rompiamo un legame
tra un atto e l'altro si riforma con
quello successivo
questo permette ci ha permesso di
battere in metalli sull'incudine di
deformarli di lavorarli a sbalzo di
perforarlo fonderli affidarli in tanti
modi
quindi ci ha permesso una volta scoperti
i metalli qualche migliaio di anni fa di
cominciare a creare oggetti molto
duraturi molto utili molto versatili
coltelli arpioni scudi ruote ingranaggi
viti bulloni che ci hanno permesso
ancora di più di dominare e di
colonizzare il pianeta ci siamo spinti
sempre più creando strutture sempre più
ambiziose sempre più ardite macchine
sempre più complesse per varie migliaia
di anni dopo alla scoperta dei metalli
non successe niente di importante a
parte piccoli dettagli come la nascita
la caduta dell'impero romano
il medioevo o cosucce del genere poi
nell'ottocento scoprimmo qualcos'altro
scoprimmo che nei legami tra gli atomi
in particolare tra gli atomi del carbone
poi del petrolio
c'era energia e questa energia poteva
fare del lavoro per noi potevamo
liberare queste energie incanalarla
dentro il pistone di una macchina e
questa macchina poteva spostare una
locomotiva oppure harare un campo
questo cambio il mondo creiamo delle
macchine sempre più grandi delle
industrie l'industria tirare in
contadini dalle campagne e nelle città
da quel capitalismo la classe operaia
la lotta di classe il comunismo la borsa
le azioni bot i cct gli assegni le
bollette tutte le cose che abbiamo
ancora oggi e che influenzano la nostra
vita nel 900
scoprimmo che c'era ancora più energia e
un'energia terribile e potente non nei
legami tra gli atomi del petrolio ma nel
nucleo stesso dell'atomo un'energia così
terribile che ci chiede per la prima
volta il potere assoluto il potere
finale è quello di distruggere anche noi
stessi e il nostro pianeta questa
energia ha causato 50 anni di guerra
fredda e ha influenzato in senza ancora
adesso la nostra vita ma parliamo di
materiali meno terribile e cattivi
materiale spesso sottovalutato o
criticato che però ha cambiato la nostra
vita anche più del dell'uranio e la
plastica la plastica è fatta di tanti
piccoli spaghettini sono come delle file
di atomi di carbonio legati assieme
cambiando la lunghezza di questi
spaghettini e la loro rigidità riusciamo
a fare di tutto dalle dalle lenti a
contatto alle scarpe da ginnastica e la
plastica e qui ovunque intorno a noi e
aiutato è cambiato tantissimo la nostra
vita
nel 2004 due scienziati russi un po
giocherelloni hanno ampliato anche il
nostro punto di vista questo è un
esempio di veramente di lateral thinking
in senso fisico dimostrandoci che
potevamo manipolare questi materiali non
solo in una dimensione ma in due hanno
quindi creato e manipolato un
fogliettino di atomi di carbonio spesso
un solo atomo chiamato grafene questo è
il materiale più sottile del mondo e
tanti scienziati al momento stanno
lavorando su questo il grafene ha
tantissime proprietà molto molto
interessanti può condurre le cariche
elettriche più velocemente del silicio o
il calore meglio del rame su scala
nanoscopica e io e tanti altri miei
colleghi siamo pronti a farci transistor
batterie
tutte cose concrete ma oggi non vi
voglio parlare di cose concrete che
stiamo già facendo
o che potete immaginare facilmente con
una batteria che è che ha maggiore
capacità oggi con voi vorrei sognare
vorrei provare andare oltre una delle
caratteristiche del grafene è che è
molto resistente su scala nanometrica è
più resistente addirittura dell'acciaio
questo perché i legami tra gli atomi di
carbonio che lo compongono sono molto
forti
inoltre questa struttura esagonale molto
flessibile ma molto adatta ad essere
tirata questo lo sanno gli scienziati lo
hanno scoperto con calcoli
complicatissimi ma lo sapevano ancora
prima i contadini per che usavano e
usano strutture simili per tenere a bada
gli animali più feroci e cattivi che ci
sono che sono i polli se vedete è
praticamente la stessa struttura che
possiamo fare con una rete per polli
atomica molto leggera e molto resistente
uno scienziato famoso una volta mi disse
che per pensare alle prossime a
rivoluzioni del futuro dobbiamo capire
questo che le grandi rivoluzioni
arrivano quando qualcosa che diamo per
scontato viene dimostrato falso viene
messo in discussione più è scontata più
la davamo per scontata questa cosa più
grande è la rivoluzione ad esempio che
la terra è piatta o che le malattie sono
punizioni divine
quindi vorrei provare con voi a prendere
qualcosa che diamo per scontato e
metterla in discussione a capire che
cosa può succedere se quella cosa non
fosse vera
parliamo di di affrontare un muro che
opprime tutti quanti noi ricchi poveri
belli brutti questo muro e la gravità
tutti quanti noi sogniamo di di andare
nello spazio ma probabilmente non ce la
faremo nella nostra vita adesso ci si
può andare ma magari qualche miliardario
ci riuscirà
questo perché diamo per scontato che per
andare nello spazio si debba volare
ci vuole un razzo un'astronave un
aeroplano un pallone atmosferico anche
una palla di cannone come con jules
verne ma bisogna comunque partire molto
violenti ed è una cosa che richiede
tanta tanta energia
ma se non fosse così un'idea che hanno
tanti scienziati da da tanto tempo che
ci stanno ragionando ager girando
attorno è quella di andare nello spazio
usando un ascensore
così come andiamo a tutti un piano di un
palazzo potremo andare nello spazio
l'idea è molto semplice
prendiamo un satellite lo mandiamo in
orbita questo satellite però è legato
alla terra da un filo sottile è
lunghissimo
il satellite in orbita geostazionaria
quindi si muove insieme alla terra
a questo punto la forza centrifuga tiene
il filo teso e basta avere un piccolo
ascensore per andare nello spazio
comodamente in questo modo potremo
conquistare lo spazio in maniera stabile
e poco costosa popolare e non saltuaria
e molto costosa come come succede adesso
il problema come potete immaginare il
filo il filo deve essere lungo 35 mila
chilometri molto leggero e molto
resistente farlo di acciaio
richiederebbe un diametro enorme ci sono
però dei calcoli in cui sanno materiali
nano tecnologici come ad esempio grafene
o nanotubi ci possiamo avvicinare a
queste proprietà siamo ancora molto
lontani però ci stiamo lavorando su
un'altra cosa che diamo per scontato e
che tutti i solidi si hanno più pesanti
del dell'area ma se noi avessimo un
materiale solido che galleggiasse
sull'area come il sughero nell'acqua
potremmo avere città volanti potremmo
avere aerei che non cadono in caso di
guasto potremmo avere macchine per
volare sopra gli ingorghi e sopra le
strade potremmo non avere più negli
ingorghi nelle strade
questo materiale non esiste ancora però
utilizzando silicio carbonio grafene in
strutture hanno tecnologiche sono già
tenuti dei materiali che si avvicinano
come densità a quella dell'area
materiali molto molto leggeri per adesso
gli scienziati li usano per cose strane
tipo per catturare delle pole della
polvere delle comete o come isolamento
termico
ma chissà gli scienziati ci lavorano su
ma tanti artisti hanno già immaginato
questa cosa sinceramente io non voglio
darvi illusioni non credo che nel
prossimo futuro avremo ascensori
spaziali
case volanti però sono sicuro che nel
futuro vedremo delle rivoluzioni
incredibili uguali a quelle che abbiamo
avuto nel passato e anche voi potete
essere parte di questa cosa
ritorniamo al messaggio che vorrei darvi
quindi le grandi scoperte arrivano
quando certezze assolute vengono
smentite vorrei che stasera quando
tornate a casa a guardarsi intorno a voi
qualcosa che avete sempre sotto gli
occhi che date per scontato e provate a
metterla in discussione
gli scienziati pensano gli artisti
sognano e ogni tanto però questi sogni
diventano realtà
e cambiano la nostra vita per sempre
grazie mille